let's get to audience questions I like
this week's audience questions first
question David now that we've seen
California's top two primary system in
action how do you feel about it as a
mechanism for choosing general election
candidates okay so if you don't know
what is going on in California they have
replaced their partisan primaries where
Republicans have a primary and pick
their candidate for the general election
and Democrats have their primary and
select their candidate for the general
election and then in November the
winning Republican and a winning
Democrat faced off that's the way it is
in most states of course California
switched to something called a top two
primary some people also call it a
jungle primary and the way that it works
is the primary which in California is in
June has anybody can run in it
regardless of party and the top two
vote-getters are the ones that face off
in the November election you could end
up with a Republican and a Democrat you
could end up with two Republicans you
could end up with two Democrats it
doesn't matter what party they represent
it is the top two vote-getters
the idea of this was basically twofold
there were two supposed reasons why the
top two primary was going to be a good
thing one reason and this is part of why
former California Governor Arnold
Schwarzenegger supported it was that it
would moderate politics the idea was if
you simply have to appeal to the largest
number of voters regardless of political
orientation or party affiliation you've
got to be more moderate because you're
less likely to win if you are really
extreme that might make sense if the
voter distribution in the state was also
moderate but as we know States often
tend to be either more on the liberal
side or more on the conservative side
the other supposed appeal of the two
first two primary top two primary system
was that it would increase turnout so
far neither of these things has happened
right so if we evaluate the top two
primary system on its own claimed areas
of superiority we have studies that find
that number one when you have more
candidates to choose
people don't really end up actually
voting for the moderates they often
actually get confused about the
ideological differences between the
extreme candidates and the moderate
candidates within the same party and
it's very frequent
it's very frequently happening that the
more extreme members of either the
Republican or Democratic Party are
actually winning so number one that has
not worked it is not moderated election
results in any way
and number two turnout went down in the
first two statewide primaries that were
held in California with the top two
primary rule so by its own stated goals
Pat it hasn't succeeded so if we did a
top two primary for the 2016
presidential election yeah any guesses
as to who the two candidates would be
the two final candidates for the general
uh so how would we so this would be
based on total votes in all primaries if
you like it add all the states together
yet which granted isn't the best way to
do it because they would have run
different races Republicans had like 17
candidates so that diluted some of the
support that other candidates might have
gotten would it but uh Hillary and Ted
Cruz Donald Trump versus Hillary Clinton
oh it would have that would have been it
oh yes but Bernie Sanders wasn't that
far behind Donald Trump so it could have
also easily been Hillary versus Bernie
in the general election fair enough yeah
fair enough and what we've seen at least
in California is that it has not gone I
listen I think that what we need is one
of the many versions of Instant Runoff
voting I know that I talked about
Instant Runoff voting quite a bit it's
also sometimes called ranked choice
voting and people write in and they say
David you know there are systems that
are better than the exact version of
Instant Runoff that you describe and
that's actually true I've done quite a
bit of research and there are different
iterations of multiple choice type
voting systems when I say Instant Runoff
voting I'm not married to a particular
iteration of it I know that there are
different versions but I think some
version of that would be far better than
a top two primary system that might be
worthy of a story I think it would write
that down I think it would yeah I'll
make a note of that on a piece of paper
after we're off the air